rich why do you sleep in a tent for
those that don't know for the last two
years I've been sleeping outside in this
thing a lot of people have been asking
me why do you do that and it basically
boils down to three fundamental reasons
the first is I just sleep better in a
tent outside the second reason is that
it really has helped me connect with
nature and the outdoors and I think our
primal disposition and the third reason
I've been doing it is because
fundamentally it's a stoic practice a
couple years ago I started struggling
with trying to get a deep sleep unless I
was training SuperDuper hard I just
found it difficult to get the
restfulness that my body and my mind
need and at the time our bedroom that I
share with my wife Julie was either too
cold for her or too hot for me then I
had an experience where we as a family
all slept on our roof one night we have
a flat roof and we did it just for fun
with the kids and I had the most restful
peaceful night of sleep in recent memory
being outdoors breathing that outdoor
air sleeping under the stars is a very
simple and basic way of reconnecting
with what it means to be fundamentally
human we live in this super fast-paced
culture you got to get your hustle on
you gotta like work 24 hours a day and
if you're not being productive in every
moment of your waking existence then
you're wasting time and you're falling
behind
and with that comes a D prioritization
of sleep sleep is for slackers right and
nothing could be further from the truth
I know that I can't perform at my very
best unless I get eight hours of sleep
and it's not just the amount of time
that I sleep it's the quality of that
sleep it's the caliber of that sleep it
is my opinion that everybody should be
doing everything they can to enhance
that quality of their evening hours and
I found that by sleeping in a tent it's
almost like this hack towards improving
the caliber of my sleep so that I can
show up throughout my day and Excel be
totally focused be totally present have
good energy be in a good mood and all of
that derives from sleep so if you really
take the time to prioritize the quality
and the amount of time that you're
sleeping every night you will realize
quantum gains in your productivity in
your output throughout your day and then
thirdly by sleeping in a tent sleeping
outdoors it's really reframed my
relationship with the material world
with those material things if I were to
lose everything I know that I'm gonna be
okay
that it's cool I actually prefer
sleeping in a tent it allows me to be
much more focused much more congruent
with my value system and to make choices
that are really in alignment with the
goals that I'm seeking without being
blocked by that fear of what might
happen if it doesn't work out and I
found that to be incredibly profound and
very consistent with the teachings of
the Stoics so that's the big story why
rich sleeps in the tent
explains
[Music]